Hello Freak bitches.
There was a video that MTV put out.
Um,
it was a new year's resolutions for white guys.
It was one of the worst fucking,
most racist sexist videos of Erythrocyte tweet that it was so ridiculous.
Like I imagine if anybody had ever made a video like that about any like
generalization,
about a hundred million people and that's what it is.
It's a general,
like if you say,
how many white guys are in America?
Let's,
let's just guess how many white males or an American,
not enough
princess layers.
Dot.
Had a heart attack right now though.
Okay.
How many?
62% of the population is white.
62% of the US.
What percentage of white males?
White males.
The majority,
which is about 77%.
How many white males?
Males.
The white men are 31% of the population there.
Okay,
so we're 31% of the population is 350 million people.
Somewhere around a hundred million people,
right?
It's in that neighborhood between 80 and a hundred million.
Right.
That's what a crazy thing to generalize.
Like,
just to make a video about white men.
She was like,
hey white guys,
how about you get your shit together?
Like just white guys.
Just white guys.
Like,
Holy Shit.
Do you want to do this about black guys too?
Why don't you see what happens when you do it about black guys?
How about you do it about black women?
See how quick somebody beats the fuck out of you.
How come you can do that about white guys like this?
The idea is that white men are the privileged and that white men have this
advantage.
So you should attack that advantage by being racist towards them.
I the best way to stop racism is to be racist towards people who you think are
racist.
It's hilarious.
It's so stupid.
It's so unbelievable that MTV news stuff,
they should do a video like that.
What's really bad?
Mtvs the worse.
I mean like,
have you watched it on TV recently?
I'm sorry?
Do you,
do you like MTV?
No,
I try,
I to watch TV anymore.
I don't have cable anymore,
so I have,
you know,
a ps view or whatever.
It's sling.
And,
uh,
so I have certain channels I normally,
but not as many as I used to have.
So like I'll watch MTV more just because I have it.
It's one of 30 channels,
but MTV is just garbage channel now.
Like there's nothing that we're too old for it.
That's like you have to be 18 to 22 to have any fun to have that show.
What does it mean?
Dickless is that on MTV?
God,
that shows just saw a bunch of videos for people getting jacked on the Internet.
Right.
And then,
um,
everything else is,
they don't have videos anymore,
right?
No videos on youtube.
Every videos I'm sending you to one.
What a weird time.
Yeah.
But you know,
it was cool when they had videos as you learned about new bands because you saw
their video.
Well,
nobody wants to watch those anymore.
Yeah.
If they,
yes,
they played videos versus people falling on their head.
People go to falling on their head every day.
So they just went where the money is.
So this is the idea is that they're just trying to appeal to social justice
warriors by making this video.
There's one girl in the video,
she goes find out what mansplaining is and then don't do it.
Oh,
like find out what?
Like what a ridiculous idea that you can be condescending about someone being
condescending and it that somehow or another is going to work like that.
All the thought behind making a video like that,
it's exactly how Trump got elected.
When you tell people what to do,
they automatically want to do the other thing.
Even if they wouldn't want to do the other thing if you hadn't said Shit,
but when you push people and you tell people just if you,
you make up ridiculous standards for the way people are supposed to behave
because you think they should behave like that and that you are allowed to make
gigantic gross generalizations about an entire group of 100 million people just
because you think it's open season on white guys like that is how people like
Trump get elected because people push back against your ridiculous political
correctness and go towards what's the enemy of that?
What's the enemy of political correctness?
That pussy grabbing guy,
let's fuck a vote modem in and that's what happens.
That's exactly what happens.
These people are,
the people that are so mad that Trump is in office are directly responsible for
it.
Hoards of people voting for Trump because they are sick of where the the PC
generation is pointing fee.
It's an irrational point of view.
It's not objective.
It's not,
if anything has to do with gender or homosexuality,
whoever has to do with any of those things is no longer considered as an
individual.
Then you're considered as a part of an untouchable group that is almost always
exonerated of anything that they've done wrong.
It cheats.
You get to this weird fake world where people aren't people anymore.
They're figureheads for ideologies and that's the problem with political
correctness.
As much as it's a problem with people that are super right wing or people that
are born again Christians or
it's fucking up comedy like so many comedians have been talking about lately,
how like they've had to stop themselves on stage,
you know,
and not go down a route.
They normally would always go down because of the recent,
you know,
racist shit and the PC shit sewed much different,
in the last even six months.
Well there's definitely more pushback,
but there's always been pushback.
Have you noticed a change?
Have you,
have you noticed like certain things you won't say now or do now or,
well,
it makes you just back up what you want to say better.
It makes you reinforce your arguments better.
It makes you,
if you're going to have something to say to people,
you have to have,
you know,
you have to have a real point and you have to be able to back up what you're
saying.
You have to be able explain what you're saying.
[inaudible].